hi Matt here I wanted to tell you about
a podcast from our friends at wish I
knew wish I knew is a show from Bessemer
Venture Partners about the relevatory
AHA moments that Founders discover on
their own business Journeys and why
taking risks leads to growth in season
two you'll hear CEOs from Nextdoor
rocket lab and Cameo share make or break
advice on entrepreneurship and
Leadership
for wisdom inspiration and real world
strategies from the Trailblazers who've
carved their paths to success listen to
wish I knew on your favorite podcast
player today
when it comes to achieving our own
personal goals
sometimes the biggest impediment is
ourselves
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome the think
fast talk smart the podcast
today I am really excited to speak with
Katie Milkman Katie is a professor at
Wharton and co-founder and co-director
of the behavioral change for good
initiative she hosts the podcast
choiceology and is the author of how to
change the science of getting from where
you are to where you want to be Katie
and I met a little over a year ago when
she was so kind to offer advice about
authoring my latest book I'm super
excited to continue our conversation
here and Katie welcome thank you so much
for having me I'm really excited to be
here one of the reasons I'm so excited
to speak with you is that your work
pulls together and synthesizes many of
the topics we've discussed here before
we talked about habits with BJ fog
motivation with Suchi Huang and behavior
change with Bob cialdini a lot of your
work focuses on how we can change and
maintain attitudes and behaviors we want
to adopt before we get into how to do
that I'd like for you to share some of
the things that get in the way of
realizing these changes that we want
what are some of the barriers that
you've identified and worked with thanks
for asking that question because it's
critical to think about before you can
actually figure out what's the solution
you have to understand what you're
working against some of the key barriers
that I think about are are internal I
should I should say there's lots of
external barriers to change but the
internal ones are where my research
focuses so the getting started problem
is a barrier you know how do I find the
motivation to get going on this we have
looked at impulsivity the fact that we
we focus more on the rewards we'll get
today than the rewards that will be
delayed and procrastination which is
really the flip side of impulsivity one
that I think gets neglected is
forgetting but it's really important if
it's not top of mind we can't get things
done I talk about laziness which it
sounds worse than it is I actually think
we're wired to look for the path of
least resistance and efficiency and
that's normally a good thing but it can
get in the way when we want to make a
change that's another challenge and then
two final barriers that I write about
and think are important are believing in
yourself really having the sense that
you have what it takes you have the
confidence and self-efficacy that this
is possible for you
and related to that is and this this is
where we start to bleed a little bit
from internal to external barriers who
you surround yourself with because we
have a tendency to conform to the people
around us and if we are surrounded by
people who show us our limitations that
can be a barrier too
those barriers I mean there are a lot of
them and as you were rattling them off I
I'm going through in my own mind the
things that have prevented me from doing
some of the things that I want and so
I'm hoping in a little bit we can talk
about how to reduce some of those
barriers and achieve the changes that
we're looking for one of them that I I
find fascinating is this notion of
present versus future and I know that
you have thought a lot about this and
done some research on this that we tend
to be motivated by the now and not so
much what's in the future what impact
does this happen what advice do you have
for managing our present versus future
goals and selves I think the focus on
instant gratification over long-term
delayed rewards is one of the biggest
challenges in terms of advice I actually
think there's some really wonderful
wisdom that comes from research done by
islet fishbach at the University of
Chicago and Caitlin Wooley at Cornell
University they've shown that most of
the time when we're focusing on pursuing
a goal we neglect this issue and we just
follow the advice of Nike which says
just do it right we think all I have to
do is want it enough and that will get
me through and we focus on finding
efficient paths to our desired outcomes
and we neglect thinking about whether
we'll enjoy the path and the goal
Pursuit and it turns out that's a
mistake because if we aren't finding it
gratifying in the moment to pursue our
goals we tend not to persist so they
have some really nice research showing
if you encourage people to pursue their
goals in a way that they find fun as
opposed to a way that's maximally
efficient you actually end up with
better results a really concrete example
would be think about going to the gym
you could either get on the maximally
punishing StairMaster or you could go to
Zumba class with a friend and you will
of course probably get fitter faster if
you're on that StairMaster but if you
find it miserable it'll be a one-time
only visit whereas if you're doing
something you enjoy you're going to keep
it up and your results will be better in
the long run I think this is really
important I like to call it the Mary
Poppins effect that you know she says
put a spoonful of sugar on it right
that's that's the advice for how do you
get kids to do things but actually this
is true for adults too we need a way to
make it more enjoyable to pursue our
goals and I've studied one tactic for
that which I call Temptation bundling
which is linking something that would
otherwise feel like a chore with a
source of Temptation and pleasure and
instant gratification so for podcast
listeners maybe you love listening to
podcasts what if you only let yourself
listen to your favorite podcasts while
you're working out or doing household
chores or some other activity that would
otherwise be a source of pain and we can
think about other ways of Temptation
bundling right you only get to go to
your favorite restaurant that has
unhealthy Burgers you crave when
spending time with a difficult mentee
when we Temptation bundle we
seem to improve the rate at which we
engage in these behaviors that otherwise
would feel like drudgery
I love this notion of find the fun and
Temptation bundling I I didn't know what
I did when I grade was actually had a
name so I love what I do grading as you
well know Katie can sometimes be
burdensome I love peanut M M's and I
only allow myself to eat peanut M M's
while I'm grating and to me it helps me
get through that and in fact it's nice
to know that you've done some research
that it actually can help others I'm
wondering with some of these barriers
have you found that technology can help
because I I'm thinking that setting up
reminders on my phone or time allotments
where things go on for a certain amount
of time could help how does technology
help manage some of this stuff
absolutely reminders on your phone's a
great example because
um forgetting is a huge barrier we under
invest actually in reminders we have
some research showing that when we offer
them for sale to people you know pay 10
cents and you'll get this reminder to do
this thing and PS if you don't do this
thing you lose a whole bunch of money
later in our study people are like I
don't need done 10 cents of course I'll
remember and then they forget we under
used reminders to our detriment a lot of
people neglect planning which is a big
issue and Technology helps with that
immensely too so there's wonderful
research by nyu's Peter golwitzer that
people who have goals but that's where
they leave it don't end up getting the
same results as people who have goals
and then make detailed plans about
exactly when and where will they
Implement those actions that are
necessary in order to achieve the goals
and technology is a great planning tool
right keeping your calendar blocking off
the exact amount of time you anticipate
you'll need having buffer time because
we're overly optimistic about how long
things will take making sure you set
reminders for all the key ingredients in
your life
you highlight the notion of planning I
have a personal goal to become more
physically flexible as I've gotten older
it's harder to like bend down and touch
my toes for example and and so I'm
taking notes that I not only have to
have the intent to be more flexible I
actually have to create a plan and
publicly commit or demonstrate you're
helping me with that notion and goal
that I have I'm turning this into
personal therapy I hope that's okay
Katie lots of people do it's funny
because that's not that's not my
specialty I have to acknowledge what
you're sharing is so helpful so I know
personally when I strive for a goal I
often make mistakes or don't follow
through I start well but I just don't
follow through what advice do you have
to help people follow through on the
things that they're willing to to try
well we talked a little bit about the
idea of outside accountability right you
might make your calendar visible to
other people or have support groups one
of the things that helps a lot with
follow through can be something called a
commitment device commitment devices
sound counter-intuitive we're really
used to others imposing commitments on
us right your boss who gives you a
deadline and says or else or you think
of the government that says you know
maintain a speed under this limit or
else those are incentives essentially or
constraints a commitment device is when
you do that to yourself so for instance
you say I will find myself X dollars if
I don't hit this deadline and you
literally put money on the line and a
credit card down their website that I
have no affiliation with like stick and
be minder where you can do this and the
money gets sent to a charitable
organization if you don't succeed and PS
if you want to make sure it's painful
you can choose a charity you hate
because they have Charities on either
side of contentious issues and you
choose a referee someone else who will
hold you accountable did you hit the
deadline for the project you were
working on or did you go to the gym the
number of times you intended to go one
of my favorite studies on this is
actually with smokers who were trying to
quit and they were randomly assigned to
two groups one group got all the
standards tools for quitting and the
other group got the standard Tools Plus
they could put money into a
savings account and they knew they would
have to forfeit all of that money if
they failed a nicotine or coating urine
tests six months in the future and
indeed it turned out just having a way
to put that money down increased
quitting so the group that had access to
an account that they could put money in
and forfeit if they failed to achieve
their goals they quit at a 30 higher
rate wow so I think these commitment
devices tools of accountability are
really important to keep in mind for
yourself again we're used to others
doing it someone else sets the deadline
and says or else or or finds us but you
can do the same thing to incentivize
yourself to follow through on your best
intentions so that when Temptation
strikes there's more skin in the game
there's more consequence if you give
into it I really find that fascinating
this notion of setting up accountability
for ourselves I had not thought about
the negative consequence right so donate
to a charity that's totally opposite
your point of view would be very
motivating I'd like to look at the role
communication can play in achieving our
personal goals how do Framing and
feedback influence our success
those are great questions they matter a
lot so feedback is important in that it
helps us demarcate whether or not we are
making the progress we hope to it helps
us celebrate the small wins framing also
matters a lot one of my favorite studies
that I got to be involved in was led by
one of my students named Anish Rai and
it was in partnership with an
organization called crisis text line and
they were trying to figure out how do we
help motivate our volunteer Workforce to
follow through on getting to the 200
hours of yearly volunteering that
they've committed to do for us and they
were already receiving reminder emails
each week please fulfill that commitment
and we knew something about the science
of Framing and the importance of making
goals feel more bite-sized and
achievable and what we suggested and
tested was whether it might be more
effective than highlighting that 200
hours yearly goal we said that's four
hours a week let's just reframe that big
big commitment into a more bite-sized
component so that it feels approachable
and you know exactly what you want to
check off and achieve this week or in
this next two weeks and what we found is
just reframing those goals led to about
an eight percent increase in
volunteering over and above what they
were achieving normally so I think
that's a nice example of how important
it can be to communicate clearly about
bite-sized goals and feedback is really
important in that context too because
otherwise you can't see am I getting
there am I making the progress I hope to
make really interesting and insightful
that the way you look at the task itself
and the way you frame it for others and
personally help I know that when I look
at again being very self-serving here
when I look at wanting to lose weight
for example if I reframe that as I want
to be healthier it's much more
motivational to me and I look at what I
do differently so just the way we frame
things in my own life has made a big
difference I'm curious in your own life
what have you found to be most in
impactful for yourself Katie when you're
trying to achieve something you want to
achieve what are the things you do one
of the most important things for me is
this notion of trying to make it more
fun but a big way I do that is through
social connection so I'm very careful to
bring in collaborators who make it a joy
and a pleasure to do the work it creates
accountability because if I'm doing
something on my own I can put it off
forever but now there's someone else
who's waiting for a draft or waiting for
a response it also makes the work more
enjoyable because I'm very careful as I
said to choose collaborators I choose
people who make it a joy that's
absolutely critical to my productivity
and happiness thank you for sharing and
some of the the work you do and the
collaborators you have are amazing and
in fact I'd like to to focus now on
different work that you have done and
one of the things I'd like to bring up
it has to do with the collaboration you
had with one of our previous guests
Jonah Berger the two of you conducted
some research that has been very very
frequently cited uh and it's on how
online content goes viral can you share
the results of that work and any
suggestions you have to make our ideas
go viral regardless of if it's online or
not
thanks for asking about that work I
really love that project it actually was
motivated by a stand former Stanford
Professor chip Heath who came and gave a
talk when I was a graduate student at
Harvard about some of the amazing work
he had done on what kinds of stories we
pass on and he was studying this in the
lab and I thought gosh it would be so
interesting if we could look at what
goes viral in the wild I was really
fascinated by field data and I I was an
avid New York Times reader and they had
this little feature on the New York
Times website that showed what were the
top 25 most shared articles that day and
I was like let's scrape that data and
actually see what drives things to go
viral online what we saw is that stories
that were more emotional were much more
likely to go viral interestingly in the
context of the New York Times more
positive news was slightly more viral
than negative now any news that was
emotional is better than being sort of
not triggering that kind of reaction but
positivity was winning out don't think
that's true in the necessarily social
media world we inhabit today but on the
New York Times Circa 2009 2010 which is
when we did our data collection that was
a nice finding we also found that it was
emotions evoked more of a sort of
heart-raising reaction the term in
Psychology is to call them arousing but
that has other meanings and that's not
what it it's not what it sounds like
it's emotions that just make your heart
race so think ah and anger much more
than emotions like sadness that lead you
to share scientific articles
interestingly were really commonly
shared more so than many other
categories of article of course opinion
pieces but but if there's something
surprising and awe-inspiring it does
make us want to connect with others and
make sense of it and discuss and I think
that's such a positive result and
something we can all think about how do
we use that for good
before letting you go I know that Beyond
studying goals and how we achieve them
you also do work on diversity equity and
inclusion and a very important topic to
me personally and we've talked about it
a lot on this podcast what has your
research shown to help in this regard
what can we do to help the goals of
diversity equity and inclusion let me
first say something doesn't work that
we've invested way too much time and
energy in we have done some research
looking at whether or not online
diversity trainings add value and found
that they really don't seem to add the
kind of value we all would hope what we
have seen is much more promising in our
research is solutions that change the
environment where decisions are made to
facilitate more
I'll say inclusive kinds of decisions
I'll give you a very concrete example we
did one experiment where we looked at
whether or not people who were making
selection decisions so think I'm hiring
someone or I'm choosing who will be up
on a panel at a conference we varied
whether or not a decision maker was
choosing a whole set of individuals to
hire right like five I'll I'm gonna make
five hires for different slots on a team
or put five people on this panel or
they're just making one choice they get
to hire one person to fill an empty role
on a team what we see is that people
choose more women and minorities when
they're hiring in sets rather than
Singletons now you might say like well
yeah of course because I got five slots
but
um to be clear we're comparing you know
for every five choices made how much
diversity do we see when people are
choosing one at a time versus in sets
and we see much more diversity in sets
and the mechanism seems to be when when
we're say hiring a group of five people
all at once as opposed to one person a
month for five months we notice a lack
of diversity in the choice set we we
come to the table with and we adjust it
because most of us are not intentionally
discriminating obviously there's
exceptions to that but but what a lot of
our research points to is that when we
have the opportunity to look at a whole
group and say does this meet my goals in
terms of the diversity I'd like to see
on my team does this meet my goals in
terms of who I would like to make sure
is at the table we had we adjust and we
do not hire five people who all look the
same we want diversity in groups so try
to hire in sets because you can't even
think about diversity if you're just
hiring one person right what is a
diverse high or that's not a thing right
no one person has diversity so that's my
favorite result from our work well Katie
you know before we end I like to ask the
same three questions of everybody and
I'm very excited to hear your answers to
these questions are you up for that I'm
ready I thought about this and Advance
prepared I hope you didn't have to
reward yourself I hope this wasn't a
chore this was fun itself question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be tell stories to make your point have
you found in your own work that that's
benefited you personally in reporting
the results that you find in the
research you do absolutely I think it's
really important I don't think of myself
as a Storyteller primarily my My First
Love is collect and analyze data find
truth in numbers but to communicate that
truth so that it's sticky and so that
other people will understand it clearly
and remember it you have to make it come
to life we have to do the hard work of
the science and collecting the data but
then to communicate it successfully and
ensure that other people understand it
and use it storytelling is so critical
you are a very good Storyteller in your
book and you do a great job of eliciting
stories as a podcast host from your
guests so question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
that Communicator I picked is a very
dear friend Angela Duckworth she's one
of my closest collaborators and an
absolutely extraordinary Communicator
she wrote a brilliant book called grit
she has one of the most viewed TED talks
of all time some of the things that make
her such a great Storyteller and
Communicator are the same she she has a
beautiful way with words she understands
that it is critical to make things
personal and to have poignancy in the
story she tells she opens her book grit
by talking about her father and her
childhood the fact that he used to point
out that she was no genius and that
motivated her to work harder and harder
and actually she did eventually win a
MacArthur genius award and her big
contribution or she has many
contributions but one of her biggest
contributions is right recognizing that
we overweight this idea of genius and
that so much of success is really about
grit Angela communicates so clearly
about the importance and the oversight
in our culture she's so fantastic at
explaining the importance of this I have
seen that talk a number of times and
you're right the the her ability to be
very clear and poignant are very very
powerful question number three what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe
Clarity brevity and vividness those are
my three
talk to me about vividness I think
Clarity and brevity makes sense to me
what is vividness doing in that list I'm
a judgment decision-making scholar so my
thinking is heavily influenced by the
work of other judgment decision making
Scholars particularly I'm thinking of
Danny conham and amosversky and some of
their work has highlighted that one
heuristic we use when we're making
judgments is
how Vivid something is so we overweight
the likelihood of shark attacks and
homicides for instance because those are
really overrepresented in our mind
relative to other kinds of incidents
because they're splashed all over the
news we talk about them we're scared of
them vividness really matters to the way
we calculate frequencies and estimate
the importance of things and it's also
important for communication because if
you want people to wait your message it
needs to be something that stands out in
their mind and so you know great
advertising great communication
recognizes this bias and deploys
vividness it sticks in your mind just
like a shark attack right we're taking
advantage of the way the brain is wired
to process information and if we can do
that be Vivid but also very clear and
brief I think we've got the total
package Katie this has been a true
Delight I I knew it would be I have
enjoyed our conversations prior to this
one and thank you very much for giving
us very specific advice on things things
we can do as we strive for goals and
change in our own life and I appreciate
expanding Beyond just that but also
talking about information going viral
and diversity equity and inclusion I
encourage everybody to learn from Katie
in multiple ways Katie hosts the popular
podcast choiceology and she has an
amazing book how to change the science
of getting from where you are to where
you want to be Katie thank you thank you
thank you so much again for having me
this was a real pleasure
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams for more information and
episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
Stanford GSB